je retrouve notre chef de bureau qui
suit la campagne de thomas mulcair en
colombie britannique
emmanuel au delà des débats et des
nuances surplus ramène la campagne sur
un thème qui est très cher aux
conservateurs c'est l'économie et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour stephen
harper cellule pour commencer ça éloigne
le débat des sables mouvants de toute la
question des réfugiés syriens ce qui est
bienvenu pour les conservateurs je vous
dirais surtout que ça leur permet de re
camper leur campagne électorale sur
leurs thèmes de prédilection celui que
avait identifié pour cette course qui
est celui de la stabilité et de la
prudence dans la gestion des finances
publiques
surtout si nouvelles sur le surplus leur
permet d'avoir un message pour contrer
les critiques de leurs adversaires sur
l'enjeu de la récession leur permet donc
surtout de recouper leurs campagnes sur
des bases plus solides pour avoir donc
les moyens de défendre leur bilan leur
vision oui en même temps la pression est
maintenant forte sur les néo-démocrates
et sur les libéraux pour qu'il dévoile
eux aussi leurs chiffres leur cadre
financier énormément de pression justin
trudeau doit avant tout mais l'un
convaincre les canadiens que son
discours sur l'économie sur la nécessité
d'avoir des déficits n'est d'abord
complètement alarmiste et du côté de
thomas mulcair
tout repose je vous dirais sur la
crédibilité du cadre financier qu'il
doit présenter lui qui promet des
milliards en promesses électorales est
ce vraiment un temps d'équilibrer le
budget ou un [ __ ] vous savez on le
premier de dévoiler sa avant le débat
mais on voudrait attendre le plus
longtemps possible pour avoir le plus de
marge de manoeuvre possible des enjeux
énormes donc pour ces deux chefs qui se
disputent âprement le vote de la
majorité des canadiens qui pour
l'instant semble pencher du côté du
changement mois une semaine qui
s'annonce intéressante merci emmanuel je
me tourne vers vous vous chargez khalil
bonsoir c'est le point de vue politique
on le voit cette importance surplus mais
du point de vue strictement financier ce
que ça lui aussi la réponse courte non
ce n'est pas aussi important que
politiquement aujourd'hui très
certainement faut pas minimiser faut pas
banaliser le fait de présenter un
surplus plutôt qu'un déficit mais quand
même faut le mettre en contexte jeu
médecin contexte par rapport au budget
par rapport au pib du canada 2000
milliards de dollars c'est l'économie du
canada c'est le pib du canada alors un
déficit de 2 milliards ou un surplus de
2 milliards 0,1 pour cent du pib
ça change pas grand chose on est
essentiellement à l'équilibré budgétaire
le budget qui est de 280 milliards de
dollars donc vraiment c'est pas c'est
pas grand-chose l'éguille sur le cadran
a à peine bougé
faut dire également que le canada est
dans une situation financière très
enviable la cote de crédit la plus
élevée du monde triplera avec le
danemark avec la suisse notamment les
coûts d'emprunt qui sont extrêmement
faibles c'est facile d'emprunter pour
les gouvernements dont le canada
aujourd'hui pour investir la dette la
plus faible du g7 et l'emploi qui est
toujours en croissance 13 mai l'emploi
en moyenne par mois dit ça va c'est bien
ouais est ce que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement s'assure ainsi d'avoir un
surplus pour cette année 15 mi 2015 2016
actuellement le problème c'est que la
croissance économique est faible et les
prévisions ne sont pas encore ajuster le
pétrole est plus bas que prévu c'est
moins de revenus pour le gouvernement
donc le travail pour rester en surplus
finalement est encore à faire dans
l'appareil gouvernemental
très bien merci gerald au revoir